después del anuncio de esta tarde de que
los ministros de exteriores de finlandia
y suecia viajarían en los próximos días
a turquía para intentar buscar una
solución al veto que supuestamente hasta
la fecha está imponiendo a turquía a
estos dos países entre en la otan el
presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán ha
hablado y lo ha hecho con palabras muy
fuertes ha dicho el presidente turco que
si estos dos ministros quieren viajar a
turquía para darle elecciones a turquía
sobre lo que es el pkk que se queden en
sus casas y que no se molesten el
presión de turco se refiere al partido
de los trabajadores del kurdistán la
guerrilla kurdo turca que lleva desde la
década de los 80 luchando contra estado
turco en una guerra en la cual ha muerto
de cerca de 40 a 45 mil personas tanto
en operaciones militares del ejército
turco como también a manos de la
guerrilla del pkk de hecho esta guerra
continúa a día de hoy no lo hace sólo en
turquía sino que también ocurre en el
norte de siria y en el norte de irak
turquía lo que busca con este con esta
amenaza de veto es conseguir sobre todo
dos cosas la primera es que los países
europeos que tienen exiliados a varios
miembros supuestos miembros de esa
organización deporten a estas personas
de vuelta a turquía para que sean
juzgadas en el país anatolio algo que de
momento la justicia europea niega
alegando que si estas personas fuesen
deportadas no recibirían un juicio turco
en un juicio justo en turquía la segunda
de las razones es que turquía quiere que
se levante el veto militar que se impuso
a turquía por parte de varios países
europeos a la exportación de material
militar y armamentístico después de que
turquía hace algo más de tres años
invadiese parte del norte de siria
atacando precisamente a las milicias de
lasiete que vinculadas al pkk que han
sido hasta la fecha la punta de lanza de
la lucha occidental y de eeuu en contra
del estado islámico y del terrorismo
internacional